morning afternoon
um as you all heard last night we've
decided to go with a uh
plan b protocol that uh
governor syslak put out there which is
vaccinated people only
into the stadium for raider games this
season
what that does is uh makes it that we
know that we will have
full capacity
and no masks
for the entire season
um
i said last night it was an easy
decision over the two choices
and why i said that is we've had four
events here that were mask only that you
had to wear mask mask mandated and it's
just impossible to police and it's
impossible to have
to just make it happen there's just so
many reasons as people forget to put it
back on after drinking
something or eating something or all
those other things so it's not just
people not wanting to do it but
sometimes forgetting to do it
but we're really excited about the
opportunity to have consistency this
season
and
i would say that
if people are concerned about taking the
uh
the shot or whatever that we will
refund their money for the season for
the nine games
we'll give them a full refund
or they can roll their uh
ticket money over until next season if
in fact they roll it over till next
season they'll get the
full 10 game season for the nine games
that they're returning
if in fact they get a refund
they will then just pay next year the
full price for their season tickets
which will be the same price as this
year's
um
i suppose that
the questions that you guys will have
will be able to be answered by some of
the people up here we have people from
clear
and from the
hospital
who give the shots and mr ventrelli here
as well
um
rather than go on i'll just i'll turn it
over to dan and he can introduce them
and then you could i'll be here to
answer any questions you have for me
great thanks mark
so we the raiders are proud to lead the
way to keep
our fans the team and the community safe
we know it's the right thing to do
we know it's the right way to keep
this stadium full all season long
and to create the game day experience
that our fans love and miss and remember
where they can cheer for their team
without mass gather with their friends
and family
and have the good time that they all
remember having so to do that we partner
with clear
clear we believe is a solution that
makes this easy for our fans
you only have to upload your vaccination
information one time
it's good for the entire season
with just signing into your account
so here to give more information about
that
is jerome pickett from clear
jerome is clear's senior vice president
of sports and entertainment
we know that clear's led the way
in safety and security for years but
jerome in particular
has a lot of great experience in this
regard
he's
the former evp
and chief security officer of the nba
and he worked
diligently to put in place the protocols
that were around the nba's bubble in
orlando a year ago so he has great
experience and great information to
share with all of you thanks for being
here jerome
thank you um i'd like to thank mark
davis and dan ventrelli for having us
here
it's it's a real honor to be able to be
partnered with the raiders organization
to deploy health pass and bring fans
back safely and uh quickly
there's so much that we've missed over
this last year and i could speak for
myself and i'm sure i can speak for many
of you
in saying that you know going to a live
sporting event and feeling the power of
tens of thousands of people just
cheering on their team is just something
that we all miss so it'll be great to
have that back
and our mission at clear is to create
safer and frictionless experiences we
want to bring people back to doing the
things that they love
we think that this is a part of our come
back stronger plan
in which we can only make it safer for
people to gather but help them do it
easily and reliably as well
last year when the skies in the streets
were quiet we knew that there were other
places that clear and our secure
identity platform could help so we
hustled and we developed and we launched
health pass
to get people back out there
back to doing the things that they love
safely and quickly
so we could not be more excited than to
deploy health pass with the raiders and
provide fans with a safe easy and secure
way to prove vaccination when they are
attending a game
um and even though i've been a giants
fan my entire life
as excited as i am to be at this
partnership i think i'm a raiders guy
now
we're glad to have you
absolutely
healthpass has been used by hundreds of
organizations across the country to help
create safer environments and we're
thrilled to bring it to allegiant
stadium
so starting today anyone can download
the free clear app
enroll in a few minutes you can add your
vaccination
record and you'll be ready to go for the
game
so the the raiders are leading the
charge
with health pass and i know that fans
will come along and support those
efforts so we're happy to answer any
questions i'll turn it back over to the
moderator for q a
we also have glenn simpson from
community ambulance he's a senior
director and
he can speak briefly about communities
efforts in conjunction with the raiders
to offer vaccinations on-site to
attendees
thanks stan
our focus here community ambulances to
help support the initiative that the
raiders are put have put forth uh we'll
be providing vaccinations on site for
those that have not received their
vaccination we'll be able to process
that here on site they'll receive their
vaccine card at that point and they'll
then be able to follow the protocol to
uh then get it uploaded to clear so
we're happy to to support this community
um like like many we're a part of this
community we want to get this community
open to 100 percent we want to we want
to do it safely we want to do it
effectively and and we're here to
support those efforts
media with questions please raise your
hand and i'll bring the mic over to you
oh this is for mark and dan
it seemed as though you guys worked with
governor siselek since your
policy was
announced right after his uh speech i
was wondering what was those
conversations like in trying to move
forward with having a vaccination
mandate on this well
first off i'll say that uh
governor syslak was dealt a pretty bad
hand
things were going pretty good here in
las vegas when the pandemic hit
and he's had to scramble every which way
but loose
and there's been no certainty and there
still is no certainty i think people
forget that we're still in the middle of
a pandemic
it's not over yet
and so
we've listened to governor sislek we've
spoken with him on a number of things
and i think what he came up with here
was uh
two two options that we could have
followed and health and safety is always
number one in everything that we do
and we just feel that this part of the
process
the way that he came up with it is uh
the one that we're going to follow
he may change at some point in time in
the next month or so before our first
game we don't know that
but right now what we've got is
certainty at least for the raider fans
that we're going to have full capacity
without masks in that stadium and
for for that that certainty i'm just
very thankful to the governor for coming
up with something that will work for us
mr davis dana gentry from the nevada
current
i have two questions for you first of
all
and excuse me if you've already put this
out if i have bought tickets and i don't
want to get vaccinated will i get a
refund
and the second question is will the
raiders embark on any kind of a public
relations campaign promoting the
vaccination
um i think i think both of those
number one i did mention that season
ticket holders people that purchase
tickets that do not want to get
vaccinated can either roll their money
over till next season if they do that
they'll be rolling over nine games
because we have the one game
already
so they if they roll it over they will
get the 10 game package next year
so they won't have to pay for that extra
game next year if they ask for a full
refund which we're also offering then
they will get their fill refund and then
they'll pay full price next season for
the 10 games
the
second part about the pr type of thing
yeah i think we're going to work with
the ambulance service on the shots and
everything else and work within the
community
i think that this
uh
process that the fact that if you come
to the game and you haven't had your
vaccination but you desire to go to
to get more people vaccinated so that's
one of the things and we may put players
or something else into a
promotional campaign along with both
clear and the ambulance service
in the near future
okay a question about the emergency
directed by the governor certainly it
applies to
the attendees at the event what about
the workers the employees that come in
here what about the athletes on the
field if they're not vaccinated are they
going to have to wear a mask
as silly as that sounds but are they
going to have to wear a mask are they
going to do that
but uh basically there's a collective
bargaining agreement that has to do with
the players and dan can talk about that
um as far as the workers the the uh
full-time workers are absolutely going
to be vaccinated and i'm not sure or or
wear a mask would they be let in without
them i believe they still were wearing
masks yeah with respect with respect to
players obviously the collective
bargaining agreement governs that
relationship
and over the state of nevada's right to
directly we're at the very top of the
nfl in terms of how many of the
percentage of our players that are
vaccinated we're very proud of that um
the current directive
of the state of nevada exempts athletes
from the past mandate already
but we've obviously gone beyond that and
tried to create even greater protections
than existed
under the current
set of rules
so it does exempt athletes he currently
does they don't have to
could you answer on the workers as well
oh sure certainly so so we've been vocal
about this at the raiders we've had a
mandatory vaccination policy among all
employees that we implemented back in
may so everybody that works for the
raiders on a full-time basis is
vaccinated everybody and we insisted on
the same from our partners in the
stadium so everybody here from asm
levy the other partners in the stadium
are all
vaccinated full-time workers with
respect to part-time workers the
directive contains the option of
part-time workers to be present in masks
if they are not vaccinated but all of
the full-time workers in the building
are fully vaccinated and were fully
vaccinated prior to this directive even
being issued
ross dimitay with 13 action news here in
las vegas uh mark how concerned are you
about right here
how concerned are you about alienating a
certain percentage of your fans who are
adamantly against
vaccinations and
may threaten to never come back to games
i'm very very concerned about that
health and safety has always been number
one throughout this pandemic with us and
we followed every every type of uh edict
that came out
that is why we are trying to uh
quickly
give them the opportunity to turn in
their tickets for full refund and or
roll over their money um i don't know
what else we could do for them but when
you look at it it's not it's not just
about you it's the person sitting next
to you and that's who we're trying to
protect as well and
it's just something again i think
everything that happens in today's world
it's almost 50 50 when you get into the
these types of uh environments or these
types of decisions and we're willing to
make the tough decision and we hope not
to lose any raider fans because they're
the most important thing to us
hi joe v hill with fox5 thanks for
taking my question do you expect any
delays coming in with this process and
what is your advice to fans who come
here
and uh want to get through as quickly as
possible i would say
clear here um the the process to use
clear health pass it's very easy
it's a one-time enrollment
so once you enroll it's a minute or two
minutes to go through the enrollment
process
but from there forward once you're in
the platform it literally is it's
seconds you do a selfie
your your vaccination records are
already uploaded in the platform once
you've done that through your enrollment
and you're ready to go so the idea is
that we want people to get to green
before they get to the stadium you could
do that up to 12 hours before the game
so while you're at home you can produce
your health pass you're going to hop in
the car or however you're getting to the
event
get your green screen going and as soon
as you walk up to the to the gate you're
already ready to go
and i do want to say that
the timing of this is pretty fortunate
for us because we don't have another
home game for a month
and so that gives our fans an
opportunity to go through the process of
the clear signing up and everything else
and they will have seven days to make
the decision on whether they want to
have a refund or not so the timing of
this is
i guess fortunate for for us and our
fans because we don't have to make a
rushed decision so to speak and it gives
them time to get the vaccination
price of the ticket absolutely
sir denise rush with channel 3. just a
question about how that's going to look
if people do wait till a game day to get
vaccinated
do they just wait in a line they get
their shot they still have to wear a
mask but how will that work if they wait
till a game day
yeah so we're working through the
logistics right now with the raiders
organization but we'll have an area set
up on site
that is staffed by healthcare
professionals that will be able to to go
through a similar process right now if
you were to go anywhere in the valley
and get vaccinated once you do that you
receive your vaccination card or that
will be documented
we'll also encourage you know at that
time to make sure folks return for their
second shot typically with the pfizer
and the modernist shot there is a second
dose that's required and at that point
then that card will then
we'll move that over to clear side of it
and then clear from there we'll be able
to assist in getting that uploaded
i guess uh for for mark or jerome here
how do you prevent
the fraudulent vaccine card so the
people are actually legitimately
you know had the vaccines they don't
have the fake cards and you can come in
here and feel confident that the people
that you're sitting next to are actually
vaccinated
so the clear platform is based around
safety and security you first have a a
biometric record of yourself so you take
a selfie or attaching your biometrics
to the card that you're uploaded we have
image recognition technology that looks
at the card itself to make sure that it
it fits the
what a valid cdc card is so you have
both pairing your biometric identity
along with um our image recognition
technology on the cdc cards so was it
like 99.9
foolproof that i don't have a percentage
but we if you want to dive a little bit
deeper into that we can we can pair up
with you after mark and then i was just
wondering being the first nfl franchise
to do this have have other owners
reached out to you and said hey mark
what do you you know what's your thought
process maybe we're going to do this or
um no not at this point not yet again it
went out late last night so
i haven't heard from them
i'm sure they're thinking about what
they're going to do i think last year
when we
determined that we weren't going to have
any fans in the stadium i think we're
the first ones to actually do that as
well and then a number of teams followed
us after that
these are not easy decisions chris as
you know they're really not
and
we're just willing to make them
and
moving forward
alan snell with ld sports biz jerome
have you guys worked on any vaccination
mandate
arenas or stadiums across the country
yet
we have across sports and entertainment
in aviation of 64 partners
so we we have been deploying health pass
for
a while for across numerous leagues what
about this vaccination requirement
we we have been managing
vaccine for a number of partners both
sports and entertainment
yeah
obviously we're adam hill las vegas for
a few journal we're talking about the
raiders right now but do you know of
other events at a legion stadium that
may be following soon is it going to be
a stadium wide thing and then the other
one is i was looking at the clear app
the ace is already on there so the ace
is also going to employ
tonight's game with the aces will be
mask only and then we have about uh 10
days or so before our next game and
we'll be determining that probably later
this evening
after the game
tonight we'll see how the mass goes
again
unfortunately we're not over 4 000
fans yet which we will be
again because of the protocols we kept
it down to 2 000 fans and uh we've just
started opening up to others
but uh other events i'll let dan speak
to that but again right now it's up to
the promoters or whoever it is that are
promoting their their events
yeah right now it applies to raiders
games we're going to work with our
partners at asm who help us book and
manage the events to determine when it's
appropriate to apply at other events or
whether it's appropriate to phase it in
we're in those dial or in that dialogue
right now we want to make sure that
we're attracting the the best events and
to the best venue and giving every
opportunity for us to succeed so we'll
work with them to maximize that
and i think i think you guys all know
that we lost two sold out events based
on the mass policy
and that is something that also came
into our uh
thought process
how do you intend to um monitor it
inside the stadium well you have a
section for people who have just been
vaccinated and are not yet fully
vaccinated
no we're working through that now but
we'll have an identification mechanism
of some kind which we'll work with
community ambulance to implement and
make sure that those folks are wearing
mass obviously people have
purchased tickets with locations already
so we don't have an intention of
relocating people but we will work to
make sure we identify those people and
enforce appropriately
time for one more question alan
yeah plenty of time
hey dan you have an event in fact this
saturday um will that be functioning
under the mask mandate that the governor
put into place yes this saturday's event
will function under the ordinary mass
mandate that's applied to previous
events
okay and also uh mark you mentioned you
lost two sold out events what were those
events i'm not allowed to give the names
of them but they were
and hopefully we'll get them back and
then we'll let you know what they were
but uh yeah it was unfortunate
and uh
but again it's during a pandemic and
health and safety comes first so we
understand why
yeah i do want to follow up on the
identity how do you plan on identifying
people who have not been vaccinated who
come in and take their mask off
you're not sure how are they going to be
marked
as unvaccinated people the government no
no it's really a good question
that's a good question the governor
addressed that yesterday i think his
suggestion was a wristband or something
that he said in his press conference we
may look at that i mean we're very
fortunate to be in a town that's very
good at large events we have some great
people that we can talk to they're very
skilled at identifying who should be in
a club or in an area or in an exclusive
space so we'll talk with our partners
locally and try to figure out the best
mechanism to identify those people again
i think that's a good question i want to
ask a question as well
can people without tickets
get the vaccination as well because if
they can't if somebody's got to get the
vaccination if they show their ticket
we'll know where their seats seat
locations are as well and that might be
one way to uh
semi-police it but again you know it's
it's tough and it's a tough question
it really is
uh real quick uh what percentage of the
raiders roster is vaccinated and
secondly what about uh people 12 and
younger who can't get the vaccine will
they be allowed yes with masks with
masks yes okay 12 and under a witness um
and the percentage of the team we aren't
permitted to disclose a percentage but
i'll tell you we're at the very top of
the nfl and we're proud of that
any more questions guys
okay thank you very much
yeah i guess that's it again um one of
the things that we didn't talk about and
again this is going to be uh interesting
subject but people that have season
tickets
and that have sold season tickets online
and sold them they will not be
getting refunds because they're not
giving back the whole full season ticket
package
so i want that to be clear as well if
they've transferred tickets to a friend
they could also get them transferred
back and then they could have a full
season ticket package but people that
have sold tickets safe to the monday
night game coming up and have made
whatever how whatever they did or if
they didn't or for reasons they did they
will not be getting a a refund or a
rollover
okay thank you everyone thanks